well thanks so much for being here this
afternoon as we discuss how philosophy
intersects with real life my name is
Mitch Dyke I'm the executive producer
and co-host of the lake-effect at
Milwaukee Public Radio and really I'm
delighted to have been asked to help
guide today's conversation today as
we're recording this is world philosophy
day though if you are only going to
consider philosophy for one day a year
you're kind of missing the point trying
to make sense of our reason for being or
why people behave as they do
or any of life's greatest questions is
really not something you can accomplish
in a few minutes or an hour or a day but
it is possible that a day or an event
like this can get you started on the
road towards wrestling with these issues
just a quick story and then we'll meet
our panel this marks my fourth public
conversation about philosophy in a
week's time which as a radio host is
above my average number of philosophy
interviews by about four in fact the
only other philosophy interview I can
remember in 12 years of hosting
lake-effect was about that Plato and
platypus walk into a bar look that
you're talking about it was during that
interview however that we decided that
Post hoc ergo propter hoc would make a
terrific name for band perhaps we will
make such momentous discoveries during
the next hour but that won't happen
until we meet our panelists which means
that they can do the heavy lifting
Kraig canner survived work as a junior
high school math teacher and became the
director of Turner Learning Center in
Delafield as a curriculum consultant his
work has helped schools improve their
performance on national and statewide
stem tests and he's also helped high
school English teachers incorporate more
nonfiction works in their classes hi
Craig
Greg Sadler is the perfect person to
help us explore philosophy in real life
because it because it is something he
already does quite a bit he is the
proprietor and presidents of a recent IO
the editor of Stoicism today and runs a
youtube channel about philosophy that
has over forty three thousand
subscribers and four
million views including the people who
are viewing us right this very second
his work as an author and practical
philosopher is to take complex
philosophical concepts and make them
accessible to the rest of us hi brain
thanks Mary and Chloe's ample is a
senior at Lake Country Lutheran High
School in Hartland where she serves on
the Executive Board of both student
government and the National Honor
Society
Chloe plans to study strategic
communications in college and over the
past summer was a participant in one of
crazy reading seminars which included a
number of philosophy Texas welcome so
let me start off with a question that
stems from a real-life experience on my
first day in college a lot of years ago
30 to be exact my first ever class was
in political science and the professor
stood up and introduced himself and said
that by way of introduction I don't
really consider myself a liberal or a
conservative I'm more of an Aristotelian
and then he proceeded to not really
explain what that meant in any terms at
18 year-olds could handle and it pretty
much put an end to my interest in that
class and really kind of Torpedo the
first couple of years of college for me
so maybe the question I have for you is
this what is the ideal entree not
necessarily into Aristotelian ism but
into philosophy for people who have not
been exposed to it or at least who don't
realize they've been exposed to it and
you know maybe I'll start this in a
strange place let me start with Chloe
who has probably been the most recent of
our panelists who have been exposed to
philosophy what worked for you um for me
it was being invited to be in the group
and then every we met every single
Wednesday and it was supposed to be two
hours and I don't think it was ever you
there was one time I was there until
11:30 maybe midnight it was really
really long sometimes it seemed kind of
boring but that was the best way to get
introduced to it because I I would have
picked up here and sat on my own
I think I probably would have read
age and then put it back but I was being
forced to read it and read a lot of it
and then to talk about it because I had
to talk about it then I think I start to
understand more of what he was saying
well just go down go down the the table
here Craig what do you think in terms of
a good way to breathe Peabody perhaps
its inflicting it on people in Asia and
everything a discussion group yeah and I
do inflict it actually I tell them
before they ever do it that is going to
be the worst eight weeks of their lives
in terms of reading and and and it's
always rising seniors who are in the
initial introductory group and so
they're high schoolers reading literally
in eight weeks what is actually a
college course in terms of the amount of
material that they go through I don't
make them write papers at least but one
of the books they still do writing
exercises and yeah so I'm kind of a bad
person to be producing because I say
it's going to be horrible and then it is
and what's crazy is because they're all
in it together though they end up really
enjoying it and and sometimes of books
at the beginning like Aristotle was just
an absolute monster to get through he
starts to make sense and it's really fun
and I remember when I tried to read
Aristotle myself in college and read his
politics and it was just like on my own
I was like well that's horrible I was
like but I got and actually read that
you're a better man than I yeah yeah I
did read the Nicomachean ethics in
college and an actual course and I
enjoyed it quite a bit nor near as much
as I do now
and I read it again actually later in a
grant course and yeah in terms of
getting introduced to it you pick
something you go through it but it's
really best I think in conversation with
others
Greg aside from having people tune in to
your YouTube channel what do you think
the best entree into philosophy is for
people well I think if you get it in
small chunks that's helpful being able
to apply it in some way to something
that's going on in your life like you
know for me and then entree for
Aristotle
with people who haven't read it before
is most often about friendship and
relationships because that's really
accessible if you start out with like
make a pact and ethics book 1 you know
everything is oriented towards them and
and all the skills and crafts and start
talking about generalship I have my
really boots people quick you know and
I'll also say to them when I was an
undergraduate I really I don't know why
it wasn't until I got to graduate school
and I think this is part of the to
meeting other people who take it
seriously and can converse about it in a
way that connects with you helps because
you know I was like well I'm not reading
this guy he's he's a waste of my time
and then other people who I thought had
something on the ball they really no no
you should try this out you know this is
worth checking out
and so that that for me made a big
difference I will also say to them that
that experience he had a bike this is
one of my my soapbox sort of things I
think that we do this academic
philosophers which I still have some of
the time as a profession we do a
terrible job and introducing people to
philosophy because you know somebody
takes an intro class or an ethics class
or a logic class or you know social
political philosophy and we throw stuff
at them and a lot of the people who
teach it they're sort of slumming their
I don't really want to teach all these
non majors and there's there's a vicious
feedback loop that gets set up where the
students are learning well philosophies
for jerks you know and you know the
professor usually doesn't enjoy it like
I don't know why my students aren't
reading the material and you know
talking in class if you do the opposite
and you almost my entire career and
taught service classes and I realized
that those are the most important
classes to teach we should take those
more seriously than the classes from the
philosophy majors because they'll take
care of themselves you know they're
gonna read the books it's the business
majors the fashion majors the
communication majors and psychology
people if we can make it make sense to
them
they get really interested and then they
have lots of great examples and you
don't want for that
she turns into a fun class and then
instead of like meeting somebody on the
bus like I want to do and I say oh you
know what do you do I'm a philosopher oh
I took a philosophy class it sucked but
of having that experience you can have
the experience of all your philosophy
I'd like to know more about that you
know so that's that's my little soapbox
moment well a notice to this yes you
know even with that horrible first
experience you know five years and three
colleges later I wound up again actually
graduating with the political science
degree so that's some level the people
are out there who could reach me but you
know Chloe you mentioned that like these
these meanings I don't know how many
people were part of your group but it
sounds you're recounting a certain
meeting late into the evening really
sounds like kind of the most productive
sorts of sessions that you have in
college you know the conversations they
can go on you know in somebody's dorm
room or a you know or a small classroom
that you know people can really just
sort of roll up their sleeves and have
an organic conversation with each other
first is the idea of somebody's standing
in front of a dimly lit lecture hall
with a hundred and eighty people a
hundred and sixty of whom really don't
want to be there in the first place I
mean it sounds like that the
conversation was really what made it
work for you yeah it was just it was two
other high schoolers and then it was
cray and we were also in like a
community room so it was on like couches
and stuff it wasn't crazy like upward
writing things on a whiteboard it was
like you try no thinking but if it's a
lot more conversation and especially
because it's with high schoolers my age
like the first week it was probably
uncomfortable because I didn't know them
that well but by the end like we were
just naturally there for four or five
hours so I started the the conversation
today by mentioning that the four
interviews I've done about philosophy in
the last week are for more than I do in
a typical week I do a lot of interviews
that somehow get back into the the idea
of startup I didn't interview yesterday
with someone who directs a start-up we
do a lot of interviews of
STEM education and I have two kids in
STEM education who I was concerned you
know wouldn't get enough liberal arts
education honestly but in a world where
we pay so much attention to these parts
of Education you know science technology
and engineering and math and relatively
little to things like philosophy what's
the case for how it really does
intersect with our daily life what what
value you know should we place in it
even if we don't necessarily identify it
as philosophy as we're thinking about it
well you know one of those sort of
answers to that is you know in the
philosophy department we've got the
experts and athletics and the experts
and critical thinking and those are nice
you know it's really great to have some
some qualified discussion of that in you
know business but you know I was telling
my class about this and teaching them
this the semester at Marquette that one
of the one of the most important things
that I do like in working with business
people or doing coaching is simply
making distinctions and making them when
they're needed and making them well
because the autumn is people are talking
past each other and this isn't I mean
you could like create a class on how to
make distinctions but it's really
something you learn by doing and I'm not
saying it doesn't happen in the other
humanities we're even in the STEM fields
because it does happen but it doesn't
happen to the degree and with us you
might say relentlessness that it does in
a philosophy curriculum so being able to
say look you guys are arguing past each
other because you mean this by this term
R you mean this by this term or when
you're asking about what does a
relationship mean here's a couple
different models
I think philosophers when they're doing
their work well there's plenty of them
don't almost naturally gravitated
because it's become second nature for
them it's interesting because Chloe
you're going into strategic
communications when you get to college
and this sounds like exactly what he's
talking about
yeah it's pretty much exactly my
thoughts what it going into T strategic
communications but also having the
background
philosophy with the class I took this
summer going back to just two STEM
fields for just a second and maybe this
is a question for Crais here you know
the the one of the ideas of teaching
somebody engineering used to make them
into an engineer or teaching them you
know a higher math is to potentially
turn them into a mathematician or a math
teacher what's the ultimate aim of
teaching someone philosophy opening what
we're trying to crank out or maybe this
is a question for Greg I mean are we
trying to crank out more professional
philosophers well that's a terrible idea
III can't I can't respond to it in part
though and so this is this connects to
the the tangible thing there's actually
kind of two things I have a short answer
no longer one a short answer is simply
we have a thing with Facebook right now
where they are going through and having
this issue of having potentially
influence the election and and what a
Facebook is articulate is that there's
there's no way that they could possibly
have done it while at the same time they
tell every single advertiser on the
planet that if you advertise on here
everyone will see it and you'll be able
influence of people and there is this
old Marshall McLuhan phrase the medium
is the message
right as the famous aphorism at this
point and yet then there's something to
that
right the medium is there to distract
you literally Facebook is built to
gamify it takes ideas from neuroscience
and that's why I get the little thing up
in the corner of the screen to make you
be distracted and keep you there and in
a second I have to have update my status
yeah and and so there's there's that
element and so one Facebook is saying we
don't do this what we do do this is
elaborate and and they are also saying
oh the medium doesn't matter and that's
again that's something that a
philosopher can certainly help with a
distinction or really anyone in media
certainly all right here's the longer
answer and this and this is kind of a
fun one and so my research falls into
argumentation theory within philosophy
that's the area where you really get
into stuff and it's kind of this
Aristotelian subset that really is
interdisciplinary its philosophy but
also other things and once fascinating
is we
with Aristotle he kind of sets up his
practical syllogism and a lot of people
say it really goes two ways there's not
is this a good action ethics portion of
it and then there's also like mean stats
and you really get a clear articulation
of that in Thomas price and so you
certainly get some people going after
the moral ethics today there's been this
revival else there McIntyre's after
virtues is the big one
Daniel West American dollars really
gotten into the syllogism but then
there's the other component of it and
and this is the idea of how do we get to
this end and this actually connects boys
stem I promise and what's interesting
about this is you're asking well how do
I get from A to B and how do I respond
to these things and what's happened in
neuroscience is cognitive psychology in
particular got its original ideas from
philosophy more or less yeah yeah and
and and that's where our soul
intelligence comes out of and what's
interesting is artificial intelligence
artificial intelligences original
assumptions were predominantly formal
logic all right so they're trying to
make this system work and so it's really
you have to make this massive decision
trees say well I expected it so plus I'm
actually talking about driving cars so I
would have to make my car figure out how
to handle a swirl how to handle it duck
how to handle a baby in a carriage how
to handle someone walking with a cane
every single thing I have to work into
this decision treatment and it's a
wielding the computer can't do it it
can't process that best the reason that
the computer was able to win in playing
chess but yeah alphago the reason was
able to do that is because it finally
got away from these formal logic
assumptions it's actually really fun
should be against talk to computer
science majors and I know basically the
ending icing on the cake I don't know
how the rest the cake got built look at
I said I'm all over that as they're not
looking weak silikal how'd you get to be
icing cuz they have no idea about it you
don't get to that to you're in the
masters or PhD what's fascinating is
actually so Tesla there was an accident
this who's this past summer or spring or
the person's driving
and basically a truck crossed the road
and the way that their artificial
intelligence apparatus programs
basically machine learning so it can
only respond to past things it had seen
well when this truck across the road it
didn't know what to do and that's part
of what caused the accident basically
for us because it didn't have anything
this decision tree and suppose like well
what is this and there's a new company
in Boston called I see of course lower
case I and then Capital ste after the
good old iPhone and Apple train and its
function actually is based on
argumentation they're they're trying to
do this practical syllogism at me
waiting for this for years visit our
artificial intelligence really start to
make breakthroughs in the 80s when they
finally got into these best stands and
reasoning Laos which come all the
philosophy now the articles I read said
it was neuroscience and well it sounded
really neuroscience although it kind of
aids they're just interplay between in
philosophy and neuroscience but this
best answer reasoning the the the reason
that this company may work in Boston and
actually build something that could be
safe on the road just think even in
Wisconsin right now because Foxconn if
it comes and wants to have right
autonomous times be amazing on top of
that so this is a big deal and actually
this is philosophy yeah the other thing
is two philosophers are good at asking
why engineers great at figuring out how
to do things very often the same thing
happens with medical technology why and
should we do this how should it be done
that's where you want to bring in you
know an ethicist or somebody who does
argumentation theory or somebody who
does coaching in terms of teleological
models things like that the question
though do we need more professional
probably not
I mean if you think about our university
system as we currently have it it's
really a sad thing to see all these
young graduate students who are earning
their degree in philosophy and preparing
for academic tracks that just aren't out
there or if they are there it's the kids
from the top tier schools you know I
mean the really big state schools who
are sucking up all those jobs
not luck for anybody else so you know a
lot of schools now are retooling you
know Marquette for example I just saw an
email they're pushing a terminal
master's degree where then you would go
to another place afterwards well I was
graduating in 2002 Marquette grads would
get jobs everywhere but now there's not
as many jobs and so you know part of
what we have to do this great interest
from these students that come to me and
they're like how do you actually do
something to make money outside of the
Academy and there's so many
opportunities I think for working
philosophers if they can talk to regular
people if they can get out of the
proverbial ivory tower and good thinking
in terms of I need to be read by I need
my article to be read by these few
people and think instead I need to
create video and you created blog post I
need to write a white paper I need to
actually talk with people if they can do
that then they don't realize how good
they've got they have a ton of skills
and academia doesn't really prepare to
you for for understanding that like I
mean if you complain their dissertation
you can do research right right I was
just gonna say this seems like a problem
that exists across the spectrum though
on academia is this idea that you know
there's learning for learnings sake and
then there's learning and being able to
explain what you're doing to an audience
that isn't as you know I don't want to
say using this accomplishes you but
doesn't necessarily have access to the
same code that you do yeah and then
someone that is I actually talked about
in terms of sales in the show I say I'm
a salesman who has a really wonderful
product and if I can just get like car
salesman right oftentimes in the line is
the shift instead of all salesmen right
but if I can just get people into the
showroom and get them to sit in the play
total deal or the epictetus multi own
and take it up for a test drive and tell
them you know this feature here it'll
sell itself that does it matter if they
know that they're sitting in the
epistemology coupe or in the empiricism
convertible maybe at a certain point but
I mean at first especially when people
are coming because they they're
struggling with genuine life issues you
know like oh we call it an existential
crisis crisis of meaning which happens a
lot more now the people losing their
jobs or trying to figure out where they
fit in the world then it's almost like
you don't realize right they don't care
where they're you know philosophy
marketed itself at the ancient times
it's therapy for the song and you don't
really care at that point what your
therapist is giving you usually want to
feel better then afterwards yeah I think
a lot of people get drawn into it they
develop an appreciation
oh this think it came from Aristotle
they know read Aristotle
do you think it takes a certain
personality type though to be able to
get their head around the idea that not
all questions have black or white
answers or you know because we talk
about STEM fields and these are geared
specifically to if you do this this is
the right answer and you know that's not
the case in philosophy I think any any
discipline is you started moving up in
the discipline there's a lot more
complex material so if you're doing an
engineering and a high-level you're
going to start engaging with ethical
questions with questions about how to
interpret prof things properly same
thing goes for our business part of
leadership is such a messy field so I
think you're right that at the lower
levels a lot of it sort of off line
logic but as we move and again its
philosophers aren't the only people who
can do this you could have a common
degree and do this really well
English degrees are great for that I
think provided you you study the right
stuff and you're not just I don't know
writing about Chaucer in this past so
Chloe you were going in again we said
this a couple of times it going into
strategic communications and maybe this
is a good time for you to explain what
that is and
and how it intersects with philosophy um
well for me I've just kind of always
been John to strategic communications
and how people whether it's a business
or just a person communicating with the
outside world and what they're saying
like sometimes if a business has
something wrong they have to have
someone like a public relations movers
are come and explain what happened and
if you explain it in an incorrect way
people hate you but it's the right place
people love you and they forgive you for
of mistaken manner something we call
this damage control yeah and with for me
with philosophy it's understanding what
I'm even singing or what my business is
saying and being able to explain that
correctly it's interesting as you as you
talk about that it's easy to imagine
craze flowcharts and you know if you say
this this might happen if you say this
this might happen and it's really about
being able to think not just about the
next step but what happens after that
happens what happens after that happens
and after that happens yeah and it's
also understanding where people are
coming from and what they might be
thinking too and taking back to like
when you're thinking about where you're
going to say okay this sounds like you
know that it's an obvious good math
philosophy and strategic communications
or maybe an obvious good match but what
are some of the other business areas
that you see that people bring
philosophy into that might be surprising
to people yeah that's you coach people
in a variety fields right I do yeah
there's some leadership coaching where a
lot of the time I'm not telling them
that I'm drawing things from say the
Stoics or Aristotle or the essentialist
but I just introduce them to the ideas
and then after that they come from I
mean really there there isn't any field
and I can think of where you can't
that's the nice thing about philosophy
and sort of extends to everything if we
let most philosophy academic
philosophers are very narrowly
specialized
looking at things in a larger
perspective but you know we did a some
consulting and some work with River West
radio a few years back they were going
through a period where they're thinking
about underwriting and how that was
gonna work and whether this would be
fair this would be fair and so we did a
report for them looking at all the
issues what where potential unfairness
could be diagnosed where it's not really
there how to respond to it and we ended
up doing an underwriting workshop for
them where we're really doing
teleological you know sort of means that
it's reasoning your ear and it is to get
somebody to say yes I'll fund your show
how do you actually get there
and we didn't you know we didn't bring
the theorists who are using but that's
just one example of a practical
application it's interesting because
most of my clients are kind of like one
of us 30 I do say that I do this and do
this but I get a lot of people
approaching me and saying this is kind
of a weird request but can you do this
instead and usually the answer is yes if
not well and I wonder if one of the
issues is really getting people to
understand that what they're looking for
is a philosophy consultant yeah that
takes a lot of explaining right do is
there's probably not a huge section of
the yellow pages if you don't even exist
anymore their philosophy consultants
yeah and I also do philosophical what we
call philosophical counseling over here
in the states it's called philosophical
practice in Europe and I think it's a
better name because counseling makes it
sound like we're doing in Psychological
crash right and when people ask what
we're doing so well we deal with issues
and it could be in terms of like
businesses that could be individually
people and their life problems could be
emotional management and we're taking
resources from philosophy and then
applying it but but a good bit of it is
the same sort of like listening to
people helping them work through what
they're actually thinking how they're
responding to other people that you
would do it
but you have to be able you really have
to be able to make a case to somebody
what value you're having interestingly
I've been interviewing a number of CEOs
for a book that I'm working on and
they've actually been asked me like how
do i improve the recent miles that might
tell that my employees are going and it
really is a thing we have this often
make the argument to common sense but
that's not entirely what we mean and
it's how do I get my employees start
thinking through the questions that
they're asking and there are a number of
I think that's a question for just about
anything
yes yeah why did you do that two to
three year olds right why did you vote
for that yeah absolutely and and so
trying to work through those issues has
been something that it was it's funny
and me asking them both one sorry
they're using like well what do you have
for us are you gonna put together a
workbook that we can go and like and use
and they're really excited because in a
sense they're trying to figure out how
to improve the reasoning and
decision-making which is outstanding cuz
a number of these people have MBAs from
either the universities where they go
through particular ones they come out of
business models particular turistic if
you will but they're always looking for
more and also trying to say well okay
have these models but now what do I do
with that model Chloe you're getting
your National Honor Society students and
clearly you probably take fairly
advanced coursework in high school this
philosophy ever come up as philosophy in
what you do
um I think sometimes it comes up like
I'll write a paper and also I realize oh
I just need it's like look I just use
philosophy and my paper and without even
realizing you know it or the classic
rhetorical structure in my paper I also
realize it a lot in my statistics class
where I'm trying to explain to my
teacher or in Mays with a keyboard why
I'm correct for choosing to write
something a certain way or what answer I
chose I also realize that a lot of
people bring up Aristotle and will just
say Oh Aristotle said this and they
expect that that makes them smart and
never perhaps and but a lot of times
it's taken out of context it doesn't
make anything so your teachers aren't
addressing it specifically what they're
doing specifically is philosophy no and
I asked that question because Greg you
brought up how they do things in Europe
and I'm curious to get your take on how
philosophy is approached elsewhere
because and it's strange I you know I
did an interview one of my philosophy
interviews over the past week was with
Simon Critchley who wrote about viewing
soccer or football through a lens of
philosophy and he brought up a couple of
European football players and how they
are really able to kind of express
themselves in a way that even if they're
not speaking specifically in
philosophical terms leads one to believe
that they really are philosophers at
heart and I've seen this with a number
of European athletes in a variety of
sports where you don't necessarily get
that with a lot of Americans in any walk
of life so talk about how philosophy is
approached elsewhere not just in Europe
but you mentioned Brazil as well yeah
it's I think it's hard because they're
drawing on ultimately European model
we're kind of unique in that if you get
philosophy in our highly decentralized K
through 12 system it's not really a
system is just a patchwork it'll usually
be because you went to a religious
school where it was a religion elective
when I took a philosophy class that was
terrible when I was in high school it
would turn me off the philosophies are
good if I had taken another class with
another person brought up Plato and
Aristotle augustine smuggled it all in
or if you're in a really you know
well-funded public school you might do
it as a social science elective right
but those are the only way to get it so
it's really four and a league and it
could be done well could be done poorly
in you know if you're in like a French
system you don't get to get through the
lycée without studying at least two
years of philosophy it doesn't mean it's
good right yeah
and it's kind of the complaints are that
it's a very standardized curriculum and
that it's kind of jumped through the
hoops sort of thing some of my work is
used in the Portuguese national
curriculum for 10th and 11th graders
some of the interestingly just some of
the contact me and they're like some of
the stuff that you didn't come ooh we
want to use the videos for that there's
other stuff you might like to it so
clearly they just want that but you know
like you know Spain Germany Italy if
you're doing the high school track that
leads to university you have to study
philosophy if you're doing the trade
school thing you don't have to but you
know you're going to be studying other
things and it's more part of the German
culture too well it comes to athletics
as well you know in Europe we don't have
the massive just juncture between like a
student athlete and the rest of the
students if you're an athlete you're
part of club and that's something you do
on your own time you don't get a
scholarship you don't get you know
special treatment in the school because
the school doesn't care you know it's
not part of the school structure and I
think that helps out a bit and there's
no Sorbonne basketball team yeah I mean
well if there was they probably too
terrible in Harvard's to play against
MIT but you know there's a different
sort of so a footballer could be quite
erudite because that was never like
selected out the way it is a great point
in our schools unfortunately there is
one more area in America that start to
come in and this is coming out of the
argumentation theory new dialectic or
pragma dialectics where they've actually
done studies are not going with junior
highers actually I think Kuhn is the
main researchers name out of in Colombia
but what they've done is they've looked
at getting the students and these are
not students at elite schools these are
they're sampling and across schools and
they're having them engage in dialogue
yeah and as they work through the
dialogues and start to learn to give
evidence and to actually understand the
other person's point which is something
that philosophy is is in part about
understanding the argument of the other
person and then
your own thoughts and responsible but
first actually understanding them
these are junior highers that are coming
out and you know they're getting
measured by early state tests and things
and the ones have done the philosophy
particularly with a focusing on the
dialectic have improved dramatically
more than once it just did
normal philosophy howard was introduced
probably poorly or just revving their
courses and so they did a test case
across all three and so it actually is
starting to come in and the students are
doing better one of the interesting
points actually to go back to my
conversation with some eventually
actually is he was talking about the
idea that you know philosophy is one
field that really welcomes the idea of
you know this dialogue in which you can
convince your opponent to change his or
her mind or his or her beliefs and yet
he could only in his entire career in
philosophy remember that happening once
huh one of the one of the people that I
do work at atm Jill saw my book is about
this like debate that took place in
France about the possibility of
Christian philosophy and all these
people arguing back and forth and Jill
saw was one of the main players in that
sense I don't really want to be involved
in this because nobody ever does change
their mind because of philosophical
debates and I think that that's right
when philosophy works there's this model
like if I just come up with the best
argument like everyone who will believe
me and it'll be convincing no not to say
that a good argument isn't important but
it's part of a larger structure so you
make a good argument over and over and
over again and after a while people
start to think take it seriously the
first time they're like oh you're for
that you know that was the key to a
stupid philosophy get the hell cutting
there and then later on you know people
sometimes it's because people who you
think are you know have something to
offer take it seriously so you're like
wow maybe there's something there and
then that tends to be the way it works
more through connections do you think
that by and large people seek out
philosophy when they've decided they
already are right about
yeah oh yeah like I'm gonna go find the
philosophy that backs maybe this is
exactly how we're seeing this happening
with the modern stoic so stoicism is
going through this sort of Renaissance
right now there's other ancient
philosophies that are also sort of
authorized like at the curious or
cynicism but like at this year's stoic
Emily had over 400 people who came to
Toronto for that the thumbnail sketch it
for folks in the audience I what Stoics
believe so the Stoics very simply put
think that we should live in accordance
with a proper understanding of nature
that includes a fully developed human
nature which stretches our rationality
they also think that we should focus on
the things that are in our control not
get upset about things that are outside
of our control but a lot of our
emotional reactions are excessive we
don't have good emotional reactions but
we want to we want them to align with
the rational part of ourselves
it's the Stoics with a capital S
relatedness Tillich's with a lower yes
most of like just you know never showing
emotion that's not really stone stoicism
at systemize your business yeah yeah
well we're being a tough guy so this
goes back to the thing so there are
there are people like if the men's
rights movement or you know the
manosphere and they got really into
stoicism because they're like this is
perfect you know it emphasizes courage
is one of the cardinal virtues and
toughness and manliness and so we're
constantly dealing with them in the
discussion forums don't like put forth
some MMA fighter and they're like this
guy is a really great story more like
nobody's not because it being a great
start doesn't mean beating people - I
mean justice is just as important wisdom
is just as important there's this notion
of you know extending or your treatment
of people as good people as people that
you you love not just to your family but
your nation and then to the whole world
so stoic cosmopolitanism and so if
you're gonna try to harness stoicism
for
I don't know white nationalism I've seen
it people trying to do it or you know
they just being a tough guy in general
you're really misunderstanding stoicism
right but this goes on quite a bit and
that's just one example where where
people come in and they kind of they're
very selective about what they want to
get from the philosophy they're only
interested in the parts that fit in with
what they already believe and all the
rest of you can describe them you're
like I don't think this one's for you
guys maybe you want something different
like some Nietzsche it's well it's kind
of how we consume media today as you
know the idea that we go and we seek out
the the media sources then back up our
already developed beliefs yeah you know
well one of the things that was actually
a fun book that just came out called how
to think he's interesting I don't love
the whole thing but his premise is
really trying to engage with people with
whom you disagree but one of the things
that comes up and not all philosophers
miss this but but some too and people in
general do this is this is a broad thing
and it's that it's one of the reasons
that I really enjoyed kind of studying
argumentation theory is I don't think
that I've talked about it much myself
before we're trying to print we're
trying to persuade someone you don't
articulate from your premises to your
conclusion it's arguing from their
premises to your concluded is least
available and if you're saying well
here's what I think you basically said
well you need to agree with my premises
and also my conclusion and in a sense
you're begging the question but you
basically are asserting everything that
I believe is true and you haven't
developed why the premises that you hold
are also true to get to your conclusion
and at no point are really touching on
what other people think and that's yeah
that falls into that motivated reasoning
and there is this kind of blindness it's
really hard actually to be aware of
other people's premises it's not easy
work but it's an important part of
having a healthy dialogue and and this
is new this sounds a lot like the art
and mediation of starting with what both
of us believe and working you know
slowly apart to see how
we can expand that middle of a Venn
diagram absolutely absolutely
does anybody use that diagrams anymore
oh yeah the garage I brought that up
yesterday actually tutoring a client
who's prepared for the indian national
civil service examination which has
interestingly enough some some major
components that are in philosophy
philosophy religion social political
philosophy history of philosophy and
we're doing about what's the difference
between you know mystical experience and
numinous experience in the philosophy of
religion and I said well think of it as
a Venn diagram some of its in the middle
some of its bold it's this so yeah we we
still use it quite a bit it's very handy
as a professional philosopher let me ask
is it okay to take your philosophy a la
carte and say you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna pull a little bit from the Stoics
and pull a little bit from the
Aristotelian zand and you know my
philosophy is really a smorgasbord
philosophy yeah so that's a good
question
I would I want to say yes but I would I
would qualify it this would that if all
you're doing is just sort of randomly
picking and choosing you're gonna get
some it's not a dubious smorgasbord it's
gonna be sort of like imagine we put
everything into a blender and it just it
always promised like a it's like a
philosophy smoothie yeah and one some
smoothies are good right but but but a
lot of them have kale yeah well I
imagine like you're putting like
radishes and beef and stuff like the
episode of Friends where they make the
trifles yeah but I think that there's I
think myself you know so I'm the editor
of Stoicism today and I told them when
they brought me on I'm not actually a
stoic you know I'm an eclectic in the
sense that you're talking about I draw
how the Stoics but that's the drop in
heavily on Aristotle who's opposed to
the stories on some things I think it's
important if you're going to do that and
you're gonna try to work out a synthesis
that works for you to know where the
different groups actually differ from
each other and why they differ so this
goes for the argumentation theory part
and you know if you ask me why are you
with the Stoics on this but with
Aristotle on that I can give you a
reason for that I think that that's a
that's probably a healthier approach
rather than just like I like this this
this and this because that's more like I
don't you just pick whatever suits your
current oh right I'm a Democrat and all
Democrats believe this I believe this or
I'm a Republican till next week when
they change it right then I'll you know
like Montesquieu instead of Machiavelli
yeah you know I meant to mention we
don't have a huge audience
those of you on YouTube cannot raise
your hands and ask questions but anybody
in the room appear in in baby Wisconsin
who wants to ask a question should feel
free to raise their hand will be happy
to to kind of work your questions in I'm
gonna pause for a second I see no hands
do you have a sense and Chloe here I'm
guessing 17 or 18 of what your own
personal philosophy is at this point I
don't really have a clear idea I think
that that's something that takes
probably like at least a few years to
develop so I think as I would I hope to
continue reading philosophy and I hope
we continue discussing it as I go into
college I think that would become
clearer but I think that as an 18 year
old I say something noticed prudence I
like it take some people decades to
learn that I was gonna I was gonna and
therefore I was going to turn to grey
and as you know what point did you start
kind of figuring out what your own
philosophy was about I mean I so say
that mine is settling but it's really
working through some of the virtue of
virtue ethics questions and and really
what is it to have a flourishing life
and I don't think that I haven't
answered fully for that but but asking
those questions because it does extend
beyond just the you know sort of
ethereal realm but into you know what
what is justice in terms of the amount
of time that has been
nieces and nephews and think about in
those sort of terms and obviously the
friendship chapter that he that he
mentioned and saying okay which of these
are our friends for season and which are
these are the lifelong friends and how
are we actually you know not in a
utilitarian sent to the real sense of
are we making each other better people
and for me that's been part of the value
in studying Aristotle and then Aquinas
--is a discussion as well of that and
it's with a more contemporary books I as
I was getting ready for this panel I
kept coming back in my mind to this one
part of the Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy in which the computer deep
thought is trying to work out the answer
to life the universe and everything and
the philosophers are all really pissed
off because this is my era territory and
they threatened to go on strike and and
deep thought asks who would that harm
what would happen if we have a
philosopher strike and and honestly to
get back to that original issue when we
start talking about artificial
intelligence you know is there a problem
when we start creating computers they
can start start to work out these things
like the meaning of life if the
philosophers went on strike I mean most
of them are actually still at the
academy right now so I don't I don't
think it would affect the rest of us
probably not you get protected either no
I mean sometimes I do go on strike what
they go on strike with the rest of the
faculty because you know academia is in
kind of a mess right now but you know I
mean they could just as well be on
strike right now given how little
connection there is to the rest of
society if they just wallow themselves
up you know on canvas and only sort of
venture out to teach classes and do
things like that what's the difference
between that yeah yeah well that's
probably what that was Adams his point
was in that scene yeah and you know he's
writing at a time too there was there is
this philosophy when academia was doing
really well
all right well there was lots and lots
of money for philosophy did something
really stupid as a profession they they
started saying oh the rest of you
wouldn't understand what we're doing
it's really not practical at all those
those who are trying to popularize and
attract and make it practical there are
charlatans the real philosophers are the
ones who just kind of you know meet in
cafes and talk about big questions and
they all they only understand each other
and perhaps they don't even understand
it but it's definitely not for the likes
of you and arrest it you can read
Jonathan Livingston Seagull and so you
know or something popular and boy did
they screw the rest of us over by doing
that you know for four generations
because they succeeded in convincing
people that yeah this stuff not really
that important so then when the money
gets tight it's no surprise when
philosophy departments along with
sociology and other low-performing
departments are the ones that get axed
you know like why shouldn't they you
know maybe they have a bigger t a better
t-shirt that would be a start that's why
I'm wearing one it only works out yeah
so so what is your t-shirt say it
doesn't say anything but this is a
picture of Soren Kierkegaard it's
actually a phosphor Rene volunteer who
in undergrad was an art major as well
and she's doing the entire series of
philosopher portraits and the style of
an artist what she thinks the the
artists ideas correspond to the postures
and so this is Roy Lichtenstein's
pointillism and so then this is from
hold on sickness unto death and it's the
opening line that about defining a cell
Oh which is a relation which relates
itself to itself I think it was slightly
Miss Korbut but and relates to talk to
me so himself this that's the idea and
so thus he has the mirror and looking at
himself she has this whole series of
them and I think they're hilarious
actually my whole office that was the
entire wall was was it was the same
students never noticed them because
there's just they they'd walk past and
wonder what sort of weird faces ahead of
the wall and if I'm just kind of an
interesting idea
engaging both art and philosophy at once
but it part of my background is as an
intellectual historian you know amateur
level but that wasn't one of my
undergraduate majors and I was also a
music major and so the Trevon he's
talking about in philosophy is not just
philosophy in a slam see em interact and
the trend within music in particular
there are people say I wrote this for
five people as a classical music shot
himself on the foot I mean there were a
huge performances the mat was being on
the radio and they said well I've
written this piece and if only five
people get me literally the only five
people get me good well that's it that's
the issue with true believers in
anything I mean you can even talk about
pop music like you know there's a
there's a really funny cartoon by the
artist Ania Demetri Martin who you know
has these two people arguing about their
band and one who says you know I like
their early stuff but the next one says
well I like their demos that were
unreleased and the last one says well I
like the stuff that they never even got
around to writing you know so there's
this idea that we're all keeping this
thing to ourselves
yeah and I you know I gather this is a
you know the Philosopher's are just a
subset of that you know interestingly
one of the people who's the hardest to
read in part cause he is a terrible
writer but he's an interesting thing
Hegel like Toria Slee difficult up at
the very top of the scale the guy who
does existentialist comments when he's
got his reading I'm like difficult
difficult there's Hey people thought
that unless an idea could be translated
into something real it's not it's not
even a good idea it doesn't mean
anything when it's purely ideal and you
know he gets a lot of flack for being a
German idealist he was all about putting
things into practice then then you find
out what your ideas actually worth and
he actually mentions existential comics
they did have a full comic on
Philosopher's going on strike they
really came alive when he went to bed
well and that's a good example of
somebody who's doing some interesting
outreach you know sometimes you can
fault it and say I think you get this
guy wrong but at least it's very sly ah
yeah yeah and I mean he's got he's got
hundreds of thousands of readers and
you don't hear about character guarantee
you'll hear about angle it and they're
doing goofy things but but it's usually
fairly true philosopher for these guys
yeah I mean great sort of like gateway
drop I firstly get them hooked down a
little bit of this and then I'll start
reading them the bigger bucks great do
you worry you were talking about
artificial intelligence earlier do you
worry about the idea of the computers
working out these things you know let me
escape that one is you're gonna put me
at mussels territory oh yeah I mean
someday if then I type into this iPad
you know what is truth and we want to be
serious things about when alphago one is
that Hugh knew plated said what was
interesting is it played on like any
human and it was because when humans are
taught the game of Go they're taught by
military analogies for the most part and
the computer system was not trained by
those and so it's interesting is well we
are developing this intelligence it
doesn't think in the same way in fact
actually when it went to chest and part
of the reason that the the gentleman may
have lost is that there was a like the
Lynch in the programming where kept
making a ghost move and he couldn't
figure out if the system was that much
smarter than him because of this ghost
move and so like you know once you kind
of lost the first match and then just
completely psyched out it so just
interesting I think I think it will be
making some decisions potentially and
one of the biggest issues with an
algorithm which eventually is what it
turns into you ready for even it's
machine learning is you have coded the
algorithm there's no such thing as a
benign algorithm now and that would be
the main concern to say oh the algorithm
is making the decision in this perfect
or if we switched from algorithms to
hristos
reasoning the best answer sort of thing
you still have programmed some of those
starting points and so at that point the
maker of it that's that's what arthur c
clarke was getting out with with hell
yeah there's that and then when I think
about artificial intelligence and if the
answers that are being made one of the
paradigm shifts is getting away from
that creates up getting away from
called expert systems originally and all
that switching to certain machine
learning but it's also a shift in
understanding what what is it been
artificial intelligence supposed to be
as a independent thing that would pass a
Turing test and pass off as a human or
maybe do some jobs for us or should we
look at artificial intelligence rather
as an interface between us humans that
we use for getting things done which
would still keep us as you know nodes
within the system to some degree might
not have much use for some of us though
that's that's the big big issue but but
I think that when it comes to like
ethical decision making humans are
always going to be involved in that
you're never going to be able to totally
outsource that into artificial
intelligence the question is what are we
going to do with the mass amount of the
population who are getting jobs could we
just put them all on welfare basic
income how do we keep people from like
saying this is a meaningless life and
let's destroy everything you know those
are the really big questions I think I
am supposing I think Hobbs would be into
that right yeah he's a good one to use
as a model for that I don't think I like
his solution you know the totalitarian
sovereign who tells us not just what we
have to do but doesn't allow anything
else to be taught it's a it's a possible
model to look at but I think we're
really gonna have to face up to these
these big cultural shift issues I mean
driving the centrist driverless cars
somebody you know tractor-trailers
within ten years from now or mostly
going to be autonomous and that's to put
a lot of people out of work that's an
entry-level job
many people were saying more and more
shrinkage of the economy so we're we're
photos with these really big social and
political questions like should we make
everybody work should we can be afford
to put up with money on welfare you know
and there and then we've got the
question can we get the politicians to
actually do something other than think
that somehow job growth earn our way out
of all these problems which is what both
parties right now are saying you know
sounds like the job for us to teach it
communicators yeah well this is where
like you know it's a circle bag this is
where like you know neither of liberals
or conservatives really have a lot of
great ideas and we're we might say well
how could we look in from the
aristotelian prison what I have to think
about this does Aristotle actually have
anything useful to say about that maybe
not but that somebody probably does that
goes beyond well we're going to create
small business jobs and we're going to
create you know government and you know
jobs and provide incentives both part
you know we're gonna make college more
affordable because that'll lead to jobs
that's that's a in effect that's a
that's a dead argument neither of them
are gonna work but that's where we are
right now
unfortunally well and that sounds like a
topic for the next panel before I wrap
up I just want to make sure that we
don't have any questions here in our
massive studio audience seeing none that
was a great hours worth of discussion
and yeah I want to thank Chloe and Craig
and Greg thanks to all of you for
helping kind of distill this stuff into
something that I think a lot of people
might be able to if not you certainly
start making about and let's do it again
that sounds great this is a great world
philosophy day all right thank you to
everybody here